bienvenido a la presentación sobre
ordenamiento de números vamos a hacer
directamente algunos problemas y espero
que conforme vayamos avanzando tú sepas
cómo resolver dichos problemas veamos el
primer conjunto de números que tenemos
que ordenar consiste en 35.7 por ciento
punto 1 %
punto 5
13 sobre 93
y un entero con 7 sobre 68 lo importante
que tenemos que recordar cuando hacemos
este tipo de problemas de ordenamiento
es que estos que tenemos aquí son
simplemente distintas maneras de
representar los números aquí tenemos un
porcentaje un decimal una fracción un
número mixto son distintas maneras de
representarlos
lo que sí es un hecho es que es muy
difícil compararlos cuando están
descritos de estas distintas maneras lo
que me gustaría hacer es convertirlos
todos a decimales sabrá que le gustará
convertirlos a fracciones oa porcentajes
y luego compararlos pero yo he
encontrado que convertirlos a decimales
en la manera más fácil empecemos con
35.7 por ciento la manera más fácil de
recordar cómo transformar un porcentaje
en decimal es que quitamos el signo de
porcentaje y dividimos el número entre
100 así es qué 35.7 por ciento lo mismo
que 35.7 sobre 100 lo mismo sucede
cuando tienen 5% que es 5 sobre 100 o
50% que es simplemente 50 sobre 100
así que 35 puntos 7
bien es igual a punto 357 para que no te
confundas lo que puedes hacer es
escribir 35.7 por ciento quitamos el
signo de porcentaje y movemos el punto
decimal dos lugares hacia la izquierda
para obtener así punto 357 déjame hacer
un par de ejemplos más si tenemos 5 %
esto es lo mismo que 5 sobre 100 o si
usamos la técnica del punto decimal
entonces nos deshacemos del signo de
porcentaje y movemos el punto decimal
dos lugares a la izquierda esto es punto
0 5 es decir esto es igual a punto 05
que lo mismo que 5 sobre 100 regresemos
al problema espero que esta distracción
no te haya distraído mucho déjame tachar
todo esto entonces 35.7 por ciento es
igual a punto 357
hagamos ahora ciento 8.1 por ciento
hagamos la técnica del punto decimal
entonces ignoramos el signo de
porcentaje el punto lo movemos 12
lugares a la izquierda y esto va a ser
igual a 1 punto 0 81
y aquí ya puedo ver que este número es
menor que este número de acá
hagamos el siguiente punto 5 es fácil ya
está en decimal esto es igual a punto 5
el siguiente es 13 sobre 93 para
convertir una fracción en decimal
simplemente tomamos el denominador y lo
dividimos entre el numerador hagamos eso
entonces tenemos
cuántas veces cabe 93 entre c
13 entre 93 sabemos que 93 caben 30
veces tenemos que agregar el punto
decimal y 10 horas y cuántas veces cabe
93 en 130 sabemos que cabe una sola vez
entonces uno por 93 93 lo restamos de
este podría ser 10 llevamos 1 s también
en 2 entonces sería 37
le agregamos otro 0 lo bajamos y tenemos
que ver ahora cuántas veces caben 93
entre 370 esos son 4 por 93 sería 372
así es que sólo cabe tres veces hacemos
ahora tres por 93 3 por 3 93 por 9 27
hagamos la resta 370 menos 279 veamos
tomamos uno prestado aquí para que sea
10 y este se convierte en 16 que se
convierte en 2 y haciendo la diferencia
nos da 81 bajamos ahora un nuevo cero
cuántas veces cabe 93 en 810 es
aproximadamente 8 veces y así podríamos
seguir indefinidamente pero con esto ya
tenemos un nivel adecuado de precisión
vamos a parar aquí la división para
fines de comparación así es que este
número es igual a punto 138 y aquí
siguen más decimales déjame escribirlo
es punto 138 y finalmente tenemos este
número mixto
deja de borrar esto para que no te
confundas bueno déjame déjame escribirlo
aquí déjame hacerlo aquí la manera más
fácil de convertir un número mixto a
decimal es decir bueno este 1 lo voy a
pasar a fracción entonces tendríamos que
sumarlo esto que es menor que 1 lo que
estaríamos haciendo es convertir este
número mixto a una fracción impropia
vamos a hacer eso vamos a convertirlo en
la fracción impropia y luego lo vamos a
convertir en decimal de hecho creo que
si voy a necesitar más espacio voy a
borrar un poco esto de acá
ya está listo ya tenemos más espacio
para trabajar
hagamos eso tenemos que un entero 768 a
vos
tenemos que ir desde el número mixto a
una fracción impropia y lo que hay que
hacer es tomar este 1 en 68 a vos y
después sumarse lo a 7 sobre 68 entonces
porque ese sentido está bueno porque
esto lo mismo que uno más 7 sobre 68 y
17 sobre 68 lo podemos hacer ya lo
sabemos del módulo de fracciones que uno
lo transforma 268 ops 168 sobre 68 más 7
sobre 68 68 7 esto va a ser igual 68 7
es igual a 75 sobre 68 así es que 1 y
768 a vos es igual a 75 sobre 68 y ahora
convertimos esto a décima al usando la
técnica que usamos para 13 sobre 93
déjame hacerlo aquí a ver si no me quedo
sin espacio entonces cuántas veces cabe
68 en 75
agregamos punto decimal y 2 068 cabe una
vez 75 entonces 168 88 los restamos 75 y
nos da 7 bajamos el 0 vamos a subir el
punto decimal aquí 73 68 68 que hay una
vez en 70 entonces esto es 1 por 68
igual a 68 restamos 70 168 obtenemos 2
bajamos el 0 es 20 y 68 cabecero veces
en 20 y así podríamos seguir pero creo
que aquí ya tenemos la suficiente
precisión que necesitamos para poder
comparar así es que un entero y 7 sobre
68 es igual a 1.10 y seguimos dividiendo
tendríamos más dígitos de precisión pero
creo que ya estamos listos para poder
comparar prescribía estos números en
notación decimal para poderlos comparar
tenemos que 35.7 por ciento es igual a
punto 357 ciento 8.1 por ciento
ignoremos esto pues fue lo que
necesitamos para calcular el número 108
punto uno por ciento es igual a 1.0 81.5
es igual a punto 5 13 sobre 93 es igual
a puntos
38 y un entero 768 a vos es igual a 1.10
y más decimales entonces cuál es el más
pequeño el más pequeño es punto no no de
hecho el más pequeño es punto 138 los
voy a ordenar de menor a mayor
les voy a asignar un valor de menor a
mayor entonces aquí tenemos que el más
pequeño es punto 138 el siguiente mayor
es punto 357 en el siguiente mayores
punto 5 el siguiente es 1.08 y
finalmente un entero 768 a vos así que
espero que esto te ha sido útil de hecho
voy a hacer más problemas de este tipo
pues para este vídeo ya no me da tiempo
de hacer otro problema espero que esto
te haya dé una idea de cómo hacer este
tipo de problemas para mí es mejor
transformar primero los números a
decimales para poderlos comparar y de
hecho esa es la ayuda que te dan en el
módulo correspondiente me parece que ya
estás listo para hacer este tipo de
problemas si no puedes ver otros
ejemplos o puedes volver a ver este
vídeo
yo estoy planeando hacer más de este
tipo de ejemplos en fin diviértete